Somali pirates hijacking ships off the
coast of the Horn of Africa used to be a
huge thing like there was that Tom Hanks
movie about it it was like really bad
for a lot of years but look at this
graph you can see that in recent years
the hijackings have totally plummeted
and that's because the International
Community finally realized that like
this was getting out of hand the Pirates
were making way too much money off of
these ransoms and so they instituted all
of these interventions like there's now
a corridor where all of the ships line
up and they go as a big Caravan like a
chain of ships and they're escorted by
like a Navy ship and the ships now have
like armed guards and like barbed wire
and a safe room called a citadel where
like everyone can go and hide they took
all these measures and it worked but
Somalia is not the only place where
piracy happens it's all over the place
and the new Hot Spot is actually the
other side of the continent the Gulf of
Guinea off the coast of Nigeria that's a
much more complicated problem to solve